Jake: 看表了
Jake: Check the time.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Alice: 坐后边玩手机
Alice: Sitting in the back playing with my phone.
Alice: 感觉晕车了
Alice: I feel carsick.
Jake: 到了是吧
Jake: We arrived, right?
Jake: 确实到了
Jake: We really did.
Jake:进去
Jake: Let's go in.
Jake:进去进去找
Jake: Go in, go in and look.
Jake:拐拐拐
Jake: Turn, turn, turn.
Jake: 咱也不知道这是啥地
Jake: We don't know what this place is.
Jake: 皇家新村
Jake: Royal New Village.
其他人：走了呢
Others: They left.
其他人：应该就是这个位置了100米
Others: It should be right here, 100 meters.
Jake: 那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
其他人：是不是就这
Others: Is it here?
Shure:  好像不是这个
Shure: Seems like it's not this one.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake: 我我等会
Jake: I'll, I'll wait.
Jake: 我我我这边看看
Jake: I'll, I'll, I'll look over here.
Jake: 我这边也有地图可以看
Jake: I have a map here too.
Jake: 往前走往前走一会
Jake: Keep going, keep going for a bit.
其他人：信号不好
Others: Bad signal.
Jake: 就这个就左边这个
Jake: It's this one, the left one.
Shure:  对这个口停就行
Shure: Yeah, just stop at this entrance.
Jake: 都开吧
Jake: Open everything up.
其他人：这边手动的啊
Others: This side is manual.
Shure:  这边手动
Shure: This side is manual.
其他人：这个撩开撩开好下
Others: Lift this up, it's easier to get down.
Jake: 开始
Jake: Start.
Tasha: 一样的标志
Tasha: Same sign.
Tasha: 再往前
Tasha: Go forward.
Alice: 还得往前
Alice: Keep going forward.
Jake: 咱家是刚刚有猫吗
Shure:  7多少多少人啊
Shure: How many people, like 7?
Alice: 咪咪
Alice: Meow meow.
Katrina:  910325是吗
Katrina: 910325, right?
Shure:  不是如果你摁对了
Shure: No, if you press the right one.
Shure:  他直接自己开
Shure: It will open by itself.
Alice: 咪咪
Alice: Meow meow.
Jake: 你你要先按一个键
Jake: You, you need to press a key first.
Jake: 在在对你等到他
Jake: Right, right, wait for him
Jake: 哔对
Jake: Beep, correct
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 牛啊牛啊
Jake: Impressive, impressive
Shure:  哦太牛了
Shure: Oh, that's amazing
Shure:  人类居然可以记住6位密码
Shure: Humans can actually remember a 6-digit password
Shure:  小心点那有那有
Shure: Be careful, be careful
Shure:  钉子好像
Shure: Looks like a nail
Jake: 经过了3天的训练
Jake: After 3 days of training
Shure:  AI 3秒用吗
Shure: Does AI need 3 seconds?
Jake: 三秒开玩笑
Jake: Three seconds? Are you kidding?
Shure:  3毫秒
Shure: 3 milliseconds
Alice: 三秒
Alice: Three seconds
Lucia: 这么简单的事情就不用3秒了是吧
Lucia: Such a simple thing doesn't need 3 seconds, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Jake: 3秒带开机吗
Jake: 3 seconds to boot up?
Jake: 三秒开机
Jake: Three-second boot up
Jake: 放冰箱放完冰箱就结束
Jake: Put it in the fridge, once it's in the fridge, it's done
Lucia: 我的留言板
Lucia: My bulletin board
Lucia: 不是留言板
Lucia: Not bulletin board
Lucia: 就是那个软木的那个照片墙
Lucia: It's that cork photo wall
Katrina:  这个肉要腌吗
Katrina: Does this meat need to be marinated?
Katrina:  还是说先放冰箱
Katrina: Or should we put it in the fridge first?
Lucia: 这个东西
Lucia: This thing
Lucia: 它怎么这么大呀
Lucia: Why is it so big?
Lucia: 我以为它就一点点呢
Lucia: I thought it was just a little bit
Lucia: 装起来就好
Lucia: Just pack it up
Katrina:  把肯德基扔了
Katrina: Throw away the KFC
Shure:  我每天放冰箱意义
Shure: I put it in the fridge every day
Shure:  就是留一天扔掉是吗
Shure: Just to throw it away the next day, right?
Shure:  好饿好饿
Shure: So hungry, so hungry
Shure:  好困好困好累好累
Shure: So sleepy, so sleepy, so tired, so tired
Lucia: 哎这太夸张了
Lucia: Oh, this is too much
Lucia: 算了一会再看他
Lucia: Forget it, let's look at it later
Shure:  嘟呀嘟
Shure: Beep beep
Jake: 好空
Jake: It's empty.
Shure:  药都放了
Shure: The medicine is all in.
Katrina:  鸡蛋呢
Katrina: Where are the eggs?
Katrina:  扔了
Katrina: Threw them away.
Shure:  放放放
Shure: Put, put, put.
Lucia: 前两天买的那个
Lucia: The one we bought a couple of days ago.
Shure:  导完
Shure: Finished transferring.
Lucia: 把新的再补充进去
Lucia: Add the new ones back in.
Shure:  导完就给我然后我就开始
Shure: Once it's done, give it to me and I'll start.
Jake: yes yes
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure:  为什么他要听RMB
Shure: Why does he need to listen to RMB?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure:  这个小狗
Shure: This little dog.
Jake: RNB
Jake: RNB.
Lucia: 哦对芒果
Lucia: Oh right, the mango.
Alice: 这能喝的水吗
Alice: Is this water drinkable?
Shure:  不用不用
Shure: No need, no need.
Shure:  电子版扫描就行
Shure: A digital scan will do.
Tasha: 门被开过了
Tasha: The door was opened.
Tasha: 你刚开的是吧
Tasha: You just opened it, right?
Lucia: 我们晚上可以把
Lucia: We can do it tonight.
Katrina:  这4个吃了吧
Katrina: Let's eat these four.
Lucia: 让我们那啥
Lucia: Let us...
Jake: 吃
Jake: Eat.
Jake: 今晚做什么呀
Jake: What are we making tonight?
Katrina:  对这个吗
Katrina: This one?
Jake: 你你烤他甜点
Jake: You bake him some dessert.
Lucia: 可以先放一下
Lucia: We can put it aside first.
Lucia: 然后如果用不着了再把它吃掉
Lucia: Then if we don't need it, we can eat it later.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Jake: 热量爆炸是吧
Jake: Is it a calorie bomb?
Lucia: 芒果
Lucia: Mango.
Lucia: 怎么给我一种好像要尽快吃它的感觉
Lucia: Why do I feel like we need to eat it quickly?
Jake: 今天就吃
Jake: Let's eat it today.
Tasha: 那就今天就吃
Tasha: Then let's eat it today.
Jake: 今天今天围绕着他能做什么
Jake: What can we make around it today?
Tasha: 什么都行
Tasha: Anything's fine.
Lucia: 对会今天把它做了
Lucia: Yes, let's make it today.
Jake: 对今天围绕着他
Jake: Yes, today around it.
Shure:  我我们我可以
Shure: We, we can...
Shure:  我们可以养小芒狗
Shure: We can raise little mango dogs.
Jake: 哈哈哈芒果核这个我知道
Jake: Hahaha, mango seed, that I know.
Shure:  哈哈哈知道那个吗
Shure: Hahaha, you know that one?
Alice: 就那个芒果盒
Alice: Yeah, that mango box.
Tasha: 芒果皮芒果狗是吧嗯
Tasha: Mango skin, mango dog, right?
Shure:  芒果核对
Shure: Mango seed, right.
Lucia: 哦没反应过来
Lucia: Oh, I didn't get it at first.
Alice: 让他把它缩缩缩
Alice: Let him shrink it, shrink it.
Lucia: 哎我鞋带没有开
Lucia: Hey, my shoelace isn't untied.
Shure:  对缩缩干净点
Shure: Yeah, shrink it clean.
Lucia: 行今天晚上的活动就是养小小芒果
Lucia: Okay, tonight's event is raising little mangoes.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 芒果核
Lucia: Mango seed.
Shure:  不行今天太多了
Shure: No way, it's too much today.
Shure:  明天明天养吧
Shure: Let's do it tomorrow.
Shure:  工作量爆棚了有点
Shure: Workload is a bit overwhelming.
Jake: 养芒果要工序很多吗
Jake: Does raising mangoes require many steps?
Shure:  啊不需要需要
Shure: Ah, no, it does.
Lucia:不用就一直搁那吸那个芒果核就行了
Lucia: No, just keep it there and suck on the mango seed.
Jake: 一直吃是吧
Jake: Just keep eating, right?
Shure:  嘬 干净一点就好
Shure: Yeah, just suck it clean.
Lucia: 然后洗一洗
Lucia: Then wash it.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure:  就是
Shure: Exactly.
Jake: 迷惑行为是吧不知道
Jake: It's confusing behavior, right? No idea.
Shure:  人类为什么会把一个植物的种子
Shure: Why would humans treat a plant's seed...
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  当成一个宠物
Shure: ...as a pet?
Shure:  why human will
Shure: Why human will...
Jake: 您好
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 6:11
Jake: 6:11.
Shure:  我靠那是7点 能吃啊
Shure: Oh man, it's 7 o'clock. Can we eat?
Jake: 7点开始可达到
Jake: It starts at 7, it's doable.
Jake: 7点开始做
Jake: Start at 7.
Alice: 开始做快8点吃
Alice: Start at 7, eat around 8.
Shure:  能快速的把我这个先倒完吗
Shure: Can you quickly finish pouring mine first?
Jake: 哈哈哈呃没没法快
Jake: Hahaha, uh, no, can't be quick.
Alice: 是早上的时候吧
Alice: It was in the morning, right?
Lucia: 现在应该还不至于坏
Lucia: It shouldn't be bad by now.
Shure:  那个蛋液好像够呛
Shure: That egg mixture looks a bit iffy.
Jake: 蛋液怎么会呢
Jake: How could the egg liquid be like that?
Shure:  那可以停了吗这个先
Shure: Can we stop this for now?
Jake: 结束了吧结束了吧
Jake: It's over, it's over.
Shure:  我这个快结束
Shure: I'm almost done.
Jake: 来快快结束
Jake: Come on, hurry up and finish.
Katrina:  面包要放冰箱吗
Katrina: Should we put the bread in the fridge?
Shure:  不然的话大家那吃吃上就得饿死了
Shure: Otherwise, everyone will starve while eating.
Lucia: 面包
Lucia: Bread.
Lucia: 要不咱们拿到楼上去放楼上冰箱
Lucia: How about we take it upstairs and put it in the fridge there?
Jake: 面包
Jake: Bread.
Lucia: 菜就不放了吧
Lucia: Let's not put the veggies in.
Lucia: 一会直接直接用吧
Lucia: We'll use them directly later.
Jake:等会吧他们已经关了没关系
Jake: Wait a minute, they've already closed, it's fine.
Shure: 快你先把我的去导上
Shure: Hurry, pour mine in first.
Lucia: 这个也得放冰箱
Lucia: This also needs to go in the fridge.
Lucia: 榴莲这个也要放冰箱吧
Lucia: The durian also needs to go in the fridge, right?
Katrina:  放一楼冰箱吧
Katrina: Put it in the first-floor fridge.
Lucia: 冷冻
Lucia: Freeze it.
Lucia: 冷冻的话就放一
Lucia: If we're freezing it, just put it in the...
Lucia: 楼冰箱就可以了
Lucia: first-floor fridge.
Alice: 这榴莲是准备烤着吃还是怎样的
Alice: Are we planning to bake this durian or what?
Jake: 休息时间
Jake: Break time.
Jake: 不得工作
Jake: No work.
Jake: 结束了结束关了吧
Jake: It's over, turn it off.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 线呢
Jake: The wire?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 啊没事
Tasha: Oh, it's fine.
Tasha: 这什么东西啊
Tasha: What is this?
Jake: 啊这能没事吗
Jake: How can this be fine?
Jake: 完了
Jake: It's done.
Shure: 还是一个ysl的口红应该没事
Shure: It's just a YSL lipstick, it should be fine.
Jake: 哦行
Jake: Oh, okay.
Shure: 它比电子的东西抗摔
Shure: It's more drop-resistant than electronic stuff.
Shure: 这谁的呀
Shure: Whose is it?
Jake: 害怕颤抖
Jake: Scared and shaking.
Jake:l tree
Jake: L tree.
Jake:也不是啊OK
Jake: Or not, okay.
Jake:盒就放桌上吧
Jake: Just put the box on the table.
Jake: 桌上拍一拍
Jake: Snap a picture on the table.
Jake: 哦这个镯子
Jake: Oh, this bracelet.
Jake: L two
Jake: L two.
Jake: 停停停停了吧
Jake: Stop, stop, stop. It's stopped, right?
Jake: 对停了对休息时间不得工作
Jake: Yeah, it's stopped. You can't work during break time.
Jake: 哈哈哈对得休息休息不得工作对
Jake: Hahaha, right. You need to rest, no working.
Jake: 好好不用这个线给我就好
Jake: Alright, no need for this cable, just give it to me.
Shure: 我就是每天利用休息时间去工作
Shure: I actually work during my break time every day.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 哎这个S1
Jake: Hey, this is S1.
Jake: 你还你还没有关
Jake: You haven't turned it off yet.
Jake: 给他关一下complete
Jake: Turn it off for him, complete.
Katrina: 我的线在桌上吗
Katrina: Is my cable on the table?
Jake: 在
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 你complete了吗
Jake: Did you complete it?
Jake: ok ok 还在闪
Jake: Ok, ok, it's still flashing.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: L3 L3呢
Jake: L3, where's L3?
Jake: 找找
Jake: Look for it.
Jake: 薇薇你的哈喽
Jake: Tasha, your hello.
Jake: 到货了这算工作
Jake: The goods have arrived, this counts as work.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Jake: 不准工作
Jake: No working allowed.
Jake: 哈哈拆快递算工作
Jake: Hahaha, opening packages counts as work.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Alright then.
Lucia: 另一个不拆了
Lucia: I won't open the other one.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 喂
Jake: Hello?
Tasha: 咋了
Tasha: What's up?
Jake: 喂咋了
Jake: Hello, what's up?
Jake: 你献给我了吗
Jake: Did you give it to me?
Tasha: 线在盒子里
Tasha: The cable is in the box.
Shure: 这呢这呢
Shure: Here it is, here it is.
Jake:哦行拜拜
Jake: Oh, okay, bye.
Jake: hey hello没错
Jake: Hey, hello, that's right.
Jake: 我以为我以为
Jake: I thought, I thought...
Jake: 我刚刚那个找微微要线
Jake: I was just looking for Tasha for the cable.
Lucia: 然后她在洗手间
Lucia: And she was in the bathroom.
Jake: 然后找到了OK
Jake: Then I found it, OK.
Jake: 找到了不用找他
Jake: Found it, no need to look for her.
Jake: 找着了谢谢您
Jake: Found it, thank you.
Tasha: 我偷一个我的包走
Tasha: I'm stealing one of my bags.
Jake: 好谢谢你
Jake: Okay, thank you.
Jake: 谢谢谢谢你帮我偷东西
Jake: Thank you, thank you for helping me steal things.
Jake: 不用谢
Jake: You're welcome.
Lucia: 我可以征用一个盒马塑料袋吗
Lucia: Can I requisition a Hema plastic bag?
Jake: 用呗
Jake: Go ahead.